theory and polyhedral combinatorics
which in in the end where we actually
talk about external formulations and how
to
uh bond uh compute lower bonds in this
model and everything that i'm going to
talk about today
is joint work with gaba brown so let me
very briefly uh talk about the setup i
mean this is just to set the stage for
the later
theory so what we are interested in is
we want to solve some approximation
problem
or some approximate version of an
optimization problem in terms of
linear programming or also stps but
let's say we do linear programming
now and what you have is you have your
approximation problem p
that has a set of feasible solutions s
you have a set of objective functions
that you care for say they are
non-negative
and you have some approximation
guarantees say f star
and these guarantees should satisfy the
obvious property that they are upper
bounds for the maxima
if you have a maximization problem or a
lower bond for the minima in case you
have a minimization problem
so here we really talk in terms of outer
approximation of the objective function
value
let me give you an example so that you
see how this model really like inter
coincides with things that you have seen
beforehand so suppose you have a graph g
you're interested in computing vertex
covers for that graph
then you would set s to be the set of
all vertex covers in g
f to be all non-negative weight vectors
and then these f stars in the exact case
would be defined to be the exact minimum
for a given set of rate vectors so it's
really just a
natural model and the reason why we do
this is to be able to
define a few other things later more
formally all right so yeah so what we
want to do is we want to solve these
types of problems
with linear programs and again there are
many many others that you can see in
there tsp
stable set you name it it's all the same
type and the way of how we do this is we
want to do this by an lp and so we have
to define what we want to
understand under an lp that is able to
capture
such an approximation problem and such
an ips of the form ax less than equal to
b
where x is an r to the d and we have to
define some realizations of our
problem in terms of vectors so the first
thing that we do is
we assign for every solution as that we
have a linearization
a vector x s and rd such that all these
linearizations of our solutions satisfy
the linear system
what this means is nothing else that we
want this linear system to be relaxation
of the convex side of the solutions
the second thing that we require is that
for every function f in our set
we want to pick a linearization of that
function f that has the property
that whenever i plug in a real solution
s then my linearization should be exact
at these points
so i linearize out all my objective
functions in terms of linear or find
linear functions
and they have to be exact on the
solutions that i care for
and finally i want to achieve the
approximation guarantee which means
that for every function f if i maximize
out my linear functions
over the linear system ax less than
equal to b i want that this maximum
here let's say it's called f hat is less
than or equal to f star in the case of
maximization problems in case of
minimization problems it's the other way
around
that's a different question we will see
later why this exists but
that is a different question but we will
see later how this comes into play
and we can do the same thing with
so-called cs approximations where we
have an upper bound on the instances
but that's just for completeness and
won't be so important
right now so yeah so that is the model
of an ap
capturing such an approximation problem
and we talk in a second about existence
questions
now what we want to study in this model
is we want to understand
if i present you with such a problem
what is the smallest possible size of a
linear programming
guaranteeing or providing such an
approximation guarantee
and the way of how this typically works
is you start out with your problem
say s f and f star and from this problem
we define a special matrix the so-called
slack matrix of this problem
and this matrix is just defined to be at
position fs we have f
star so the guarantee minus f of s and
now what we do with this matrix and
we've seen a second why we want to do
this
we compute a special factorization of
this matrix a so-called
say non-negative matrix factorization
where we write m as the sum of a
non-negative matrix factorization plus
some extra factor that is not important
for us right now
and the reason why we want to do this
type of factorization is
because there's a very nice
factorization theorem that equates the
size of the smallest possible linear
program
capturing our problem has to be equal to
the non-negative rank or the ap
rank of this matrix m here so the
existence question is answered with this
as well
if i present you with a problem you
write down this matrix you compute
the factorization for this matrix and
the smallest possible factorization is
the smallest possible linear program
that you can obtain
to capture this problem so i'm sorry
um never mind what are s
f and so s is solutions f is functions
and f star approximation guarantees
so upper bounds on the function on the
maximum let's say
so if star is a function as well from
the solution or is it
just a number it's just a number for
every f you have an upper bound on the
maximum value
so yeah
so the f star is really just an upper
bound
on the maximum of
over f s and s of f s
so it's just an upper bound on the
maximum
okay and if you set this to be equal to
the maximum then you scare for the exact
problem
okay so yeah so the reason why you care
for this is really because you have this
factorization theorem that equates the
size of the smallest possible linear
program
with the non-negative rank of this
matrix plus minus this extra
one rank one factor that we need for
approximations
but that's not so important right now
the reason why you care for this model
or why you like or why you might like
this model is
because it has a lot of very nice
properties so first of all
one very nice property is that if you
compute this optimal linear program
this optimal linear program will be of a
very simple form this optimal linear
program will be just the non-negative
authent
together with these encodings that you
get from the non-negative matrix
factorization
so these encodings are that for every xs
where you had to pick a vector
you pick this us which is the right
vector of the factorization
and for the functions you have some term
that we don't care for right now
and then you take this left vector t
here to define the actual function the
linearization
so the linearization is provided by you
from the non-negative matrix
factorization
this model has a lot of other very nice
properties that make it make it very
compelling to study this mod
model in particular we talked yesterday
about kernelization
or we had to talk about canonization
that's something very similar here
because we have a model a computational
model in this case lps
and everything that you do within this
model is independent of p versus np
so if you can provide a lower bound
within that model that is
completely independent of any complexity
theoretic assumption and so you can
study the specific computational model
uh within that framework there are many
many other nice
nice properties from that specific model
in particular that you can read off the
optimal solutions
as we will see in a second but let me
give you maybe a picture to make the
whole picture
to make the whole story a bit more
concise so what happens is you start
with the optimization problem that is
given by solutions functions and
guarantees
then you compute this non-negative
matrix factorization what this
non-negative matrix factorization
does it actually computes a
representation of this problem
as a linear program and it does the
following so first you get these
encodings of the xs
and then the convex hull of these
vectors
is the the convex cell of the solutions
that you care for in that specific
encoding
you have the non-negative ortho that's
your optimal linear program
and then you have potentially optimal
solutions these
are the red ones they might be optimal
for some function f
and you have some orange ones here they
can never be optimal for any function
and the reason is because they're
dominated by some other red one here
and all these functions by the way of
how they are built because it's a
non-negative matrix factorizations
these t factors here are all positive
and they have a minus here
so all these normals are pointing
towards the zero okay
they're all pointing in this direction
here so for all these
problems for every one of these
objective functions you can even read
off the optimal solution which is just a
zero
which is a bit surprising but the the
the
key point is that all the computation of
solving these problems
goes actually into computing the
non-negative matrix factorization
so that's really the hard part and it
somehow simultaneously solves all these
optimization problems at the same site
a time and picks an optimal encoding so
that's just to give you guys a bit of a
background
why i'm interested in these non-negative
matrix factorizations and
of course what i would like to do now is
i'd like to talk a bit about what this
has to do with information theory
and how you can work with this so
the key point if you want to say
something about the size that you need
to solve a any optimization problem with
the linear program
is always you need to study the slack
matrix of the problem and you have to
compute the lower one for the
non-negative rank
and lower boiling the non-negative rank
tends to be a hard problem
there are several techniques out there
and one specific technique is an
information theory
theoretic one that's the one that i'm
going to talk about or it's in some
sense one might argue that this
information theoretic notion
is the right notion to look at these
problems in a certain limit sense uh
yeah so let me very briefly uh make sure
that we are all on the same page
these are just some very basic
definitions i assume that you're all
familiar with those
what is maybe a bit i'm not sure if
everybody knows this one but
we will use the direct sum property
which says that if you have a set of
mutually independent random variables
then the mutual information of some
random variable x and that is lower
bonded by the sum of the informations
and we will be using the hellinger
distance
squared here you have two distributions
pi one and pi two
and then the hellinger distance squared
between the two is just one minus
sum over the pi's that's the that ranges
over the domains
and that's just the arithmetic mean of
the of the probabilities here
so what does this have to do now with
non-negative matrix factorization
and the dear is actually a very simple
one let's suppose you have the slack
matrix that you constructed by
writing on all the functions and all the
solutions that you care for
and now let's assume that we normalize
this matrix
to have one or one then we can think of
this matrix as being a probability
distribution over functions and
solutions
okay and that means we have a very
complicated probability distribution now
over functions and distributions and
what does a non-negative matrix
factorization do now
well it tries to represent this matrix m
that is
potentially complicated as the sum of
simple
rank 1 matrices non-negative right so we
want to write m
in that form here but what does this
mean if we think about it for a second
what does it mean to be a rank 1 matrix
well it means that the probability
distribution coming from this
is actually a product distribution okay
that means now
i have an object here highly complicated
and i want to write it as a sum
or convex combination of simple objects
where there's no correlation so
somewhere this correlation information
has to go
and in fact the only way where it can go
into is in the probability distribution
of picking the rank one factors
so the distribution over these pies here
all this information has to somehow go
in there
and that's the whole idea of now using
information theoretic methods
to lower bound the information that goes
into these pies
so how does this work well
theorems that were described yesterday
which is also of a similar
kind it's a good question i don't know
i'm not sure i mean maybe we can discuss
this later but offline i i thought about
it but
i don't have a concise answer um
yeah so the approach now what you do is
the following i mean uh that is a
very well known it's not very well known
it's very old that's the so-called
notion of common information that goes
back to winer
and the idea is a very simple one so you
have you we can also reca
recast this in a slightly different
setup suppose you have your matrix m
and you want to sample that distribution
but you want to sample it in such a way
that alice and bob do this independently
of each other
well there's correlation so they cannot
sample independently of each other
obviously
so you have to do something so what you
want to do is you want to know how much
information
how many bits do you have to send to
each one of them to synchronize them in
some way
so that they can independently of each
other sample the distribution that you
care for
and that's really what this notion of
common information captures it's the
amount of information that you need to
share beforehand so that you
synchronize alice and bob to be able to
to sample that quantity and it's really
defined as the infimum
of the mutual information of f and s
this is alice and bob say
your non-negative matrix factorization
pi and some conditional the conditional
you need to fine-tune the distribution
that's not so important right now and
the reason why you care for this notion
is because this notion in a very natural
way is a lower one on the non-negative
rank
you can see this with very simple
transformations
namely common information has these
information terms in here they are all
upper bound by the
respective entropy terms here that you
have here but if you now pick the
optimal factorization
uh that is definitely the log of the
non-negative rank because that's the
range so you get a lower bond on the
non-negative rank
or the log non-negative rank so you just
this common information thing could you
say that again slowly i'm
just having a little trouble processing
all the letters okay so so the comment
so
so the so the way of how i write it so f
and s
is a joint distribution over the rows
and columns of the matrix f
are the function s are the solutions and
then you have the pi
that's a non-negative matrix
factorization it's a distribution over
potential non-negative
factors and think of the pi being a
random variable
that makes a and b independent or f and
s independent conditioning on pi
that's what it does okay so you really
want to know
how complex how much information does pi
need to know
about f of f and s together
and then we want to take the optimal pi
that we can find because that's the
minimum information that we need to
share beforehand
so that alice and bob independently of
each other can uh
sample from the distribution
will allow us to fine tune the
distribution
so i can use the z because it will
change my conditional distribution
of alice and bob so that
you need this for several reasons one is
you have you might only have a partial
matrix
so you don't know the full matrix so you
need to condition on the things that you
know
but it could also be that you have a
matrix where the joint distribution is
such that you have very low overall
entropy and you want to condition such a
way that you increase the mutual
information
right conditioning for mutual
information can actually increase mutual
information
and that's exactly how it will be used
here
is the common information always pretty
close to the right here could it be much
less
uh so that is actually a very
interesting question so if we
so the comment is okay so let me phrase
it like this what certain entropy is for
a random variable
is what common information is for the
non-negative rank namely if you take the
log non-negative rank
of the nth power of your matrix like the
nth tensor
and you divide by n you take the limit
of n to infinity then this converges to
the common information
so in a well-defined limit sense common
information is
really the same it's like the amortized
log amortized non-negative rank
so yes so they can so that's in the
limit but they can be very far away
for actual matrices they can like
have arbitrary separation constant
versus non-constant uh
yeah any any separation that you want
just explain what's the middle term now
with replacing by the entropy there yeah
yes so this is this one here right
and this you can just upper bound by the
entropy of pi
because it's mutual information right
this one is entropy of pi
minus entropy of pi given f comma s
forgetting about the conditional
but the entropy is always non-negative
so can upper bound this term here
simply by this entropy term this doesn't
have a name
this doesn't have a name like this no
no it's just like the entropy of the
factors of the distribution yeah what if
conditional independence you require
could you
decide the one that say that pi
so there are two okay yeah so there are
two conditional independencies that you
need
so the first one is the simple one that
requires it to be a non-negative matrix
factorization
that is just that you want that f and s
are independent given pi
that is just an information theoretic or
probabilistic way of saying that you
have a non-negative matrix factorization
the second one just says that
pi is independent of that given f s
this means that you don't learn from the
conditional
so that the in the the matrix
factorization cannot
incorporate or anticipate knowledge that
comes from the conditioning
it's a technical condition i mean this
chain here also holds without this
condition
but you get stronger bound if you add it
and this is valid for all the
conditions that we know yeah so that's
that's the
so that's the approach that we are going
to take we take this uh common
information and with this we now allow
upon the log non-negative rank
particularly because it captures the log
non-negative rank in the limit
okay let's uh yeah so then there's one
more important property that we will be
using that's the so-called cut and paste
property
you know this may be from communication
complexity but that's the non-negative
matrix equivalent
version it has the same type of flavor
but it works a bit differently
so if we take the induced distribution
of pi
if i look in a specific position the
matrix say a and b
so you take your in matrix entry a b
and you look at how the pi's are
distributed at this position that's what
pi
a b is here then if you now take the
geometric mean of the entries over the
main diagonal over say two pairs of
entries
times one minus the hellinger distance
of the respective induced distribution
that has to be equal
to doing the same thing over the off
diagonal
minus times 1 minus respect to
phalangeal distance
looks maybe complicated is very easy to
prove and has a very natural
interpretation uh let's make an example
let's suppose our matrix looks like this
and let's uh just apply this for this
matrix here so these are our four
entries that's f1 s1 that's uh f2 s2 and
so on and so forth
so this thing here the root of this
product here is going to be zero right
because i have a zero here
and this one here is going to be one
because they are both one
so i get zero is equal to one minus this
uh hellenism distance squared of these
two
probability distributions and if i work
this out what this says is that the
hedinger distance squared
of pi f1 s2 and pi 2 f2 s1 is equal to 1
but that means that for any pi that you
can pick
the distance between the two
distribution if you compare them at the
two respective positions is one
but that means nothing else but they
cannot be in the same rank one factor
right if you look if you think of how
hell engine distance works it means that
they cannot be in the same rank one
vector
so suddenly you get a very nice
criterion that lets you read
off the matrix when two entries can be
the same rank one vector or not
namely just by this cut and paste
property and in fact what this gives
rise to is an information theoretic
version of the fulling set method
so you know the fooling set method from
communication complexity you do the same
thing
and you can do this information
theoretically in particular i don't need
a zero here i can put anything else here
right i can work with any small number
and the formula still works
and we'll separate the two yeah so
that's that's the technology that we're
going to use to say something about
a non-negative rank of certain matrices
and hence of the size of linear programs
so what's the general strategy the
general strategy when you now want to
establish a lower bond for any one of
these optimization problems works as
follows
in the first step you search for a
conditional that
that has the following property it will
decompose the problem
into a set of smaller chunk problems say
of constant size
okay so that what the conditional does
is it makes
it makes certain parts of the problem
independent so that it decomposes into
sub problems
each of constant size and then you can
apply the direct sum theorem
so suddenly this mutual information term
that you wanted to bound that comes from
the common information
is now avoided by the sum of these
mutual information terms for constant
size problems
this ranges say over l copies and that
in term is lower bought by a times the
minimum that you can have for each one
of them
obviously and now what you do in the
second step is now you only have to take
care
of this specific term here so the next
step you use either some polyhedral
argument
or some information theoretic argument
to lower bound
this quantity here for any potential
non-negative matrix factorization and we
will see in an example that this tends
to be pretty
easy and then you're done why are you
done well because the formulation
complexity of your problem was equal to
the non-negative rank of its slack
matrix
and that in terms is lower one by two
times number of copies times constant
for the
subproblem and that allows you to
establish an exponential size lower
bound
on on the number of inequalities that
you need to
capture your optimization problem what's
nice about this whole theory and
is that you automatically get
inapproximability results information
theory
think of it as continuous counting in
some sense everything is continuous
so if you do it the right way everything
that i do for the exact problem where i
have
zeros in my slack matrix maybe i can
immediately carry over to approximations
of problems and i get
um strong results typically from exactly
the same methodology i don't even need
to change the proof
i just need to work out the taylor
approximations maybe a bit more careful
than i would have done beforehand yeah
and what i want to do now is i want to
give you
an indication of how this can be done
for a specific problem of interest in
fact this was the first problem
that people studied in the context of
extension problem
extension complexity and size of linear
programs
and that's the so-called correlation
polytope and this has a couple of other
nice
properties in fact it's very amenable to
these information theoretic techniques
all right so let's talk about the setup
so the functions that we'll be
considering here of the following form
you have zero one strings of length n
these ones here
and then for every x that is also binary
we just consider functions of the form
one minus x transpose b
squared and my solutions are simply
these vectors
x here that are binary strings of length
n and if i now write down this
so-called slack matrix the way of how
this matrix looks like in dimension n
or for strings of lens n it's just that
at position x b
i have one minus x transpose b squared
and this matrix has the nice property
that it contains the so-called unique
disjointness matrix
and so i can uh yeah i that would be
very helpful for us in a second
and polyhedrally this is more or less
equivalent to look at the correlation
polytope
of course these are only some valid
functions here but that's good enough
for us to establish the lower bond
and from this one if you have a lower
bond for this one you get lower bonds
for all other types of polytope such as
tsp
such as stable set knapsack vertex cover
you name it
that all follows from this one if you
have the first one it's like your master
problem like three set incompatibility
or a computational complexity good so
how do we do this now well
let's uh we want to use this fact that
this contains the unique disjointness
matrix the sub-matrix but what does
unique disjointness mean
well i have strings a and b of length n
there are two interesting cases for us
if they are disjoined i put some
constant c here that's just from
normalization
and if they are not disjoint i put
something that is slightly smaller
namely say c times 1 minus epsilon
if it would be exact unique disjoint as
i would put a 0 there but i want to do
also approximations so i put a 1 minus
epsilon there
so that's the distribution that we care
for and you see i haven't said anything
about intersections of more than
one or element and in fact that's what
the conditioning will take care of
because we won't look at these positions
so the next step we do something that is
very well known uh when we
try to improve lower bounds for unique
disjointers in terms of information
theory we flip a set of independent
coins
n of them and depending on the outcome
of the coin we either force the a i to
be zero or the b
i to be zero what does this mean i force
my strings to be disjoint
right because at any given for every
given coordinate of my two strings
i force one of them to be zero and the
other one is is independent
so i get disjoint strings and that's
what this conditional does
this conditional does something else
which is very nice because everything is
disjoint
and i did this in a way which is only
involves every coordinate
it makes the pairs a i b i as pairs
or independent of each other because the
conditional does only something for a
coordinate
but that means now if i want to like
apply my information theoretic machinery
i take the log non-negative rank which
is lower bonded by the information
of a b and pi here pi
is the minimal factorization that you
can obtain say from the optimal
non-negative matrix factorization
given your conditional that in terms is
lower bonded by the sum of these
information
terms uh where i have now a ibis here
and what we will be seeing in a second
is that we can lower bound this by
epsilon over a times
n so what is this now here well this is
just the logical end right
i mean this is just one bit the one bit
unique disjointness problem now
and that will be what will help us a lot
to establish a lower bond
so let's see how this is done let's
study this term
of interest so we have the mutual
information of aib
a1 b1 and my factorization given this
conditional
working it out because the coin was fair
means nothing else but
i either force a1 to be 0 or i force b1
to be 0 both happen with probability 50
and i care for this information quantity
now
since one of them is fixed here this is
a binary random variable only this joint
distribution
that means that you can apply a very
nice lemma by josef at r which states
that
if you now have a term of that form here
you can lower bound these information
terms by the hellinger distance squared
of the the marginal distributions on
your pi
so what you have if i fix a1 to be zero
the choices for b are zero and 1 so i
take h squared of pi
0 0 versus pi 0 1 and for the other one
i do it the other way around
so now it's very tempting to just plug
this
up in there and try to estimate this and
and be done but there's a problem with
this and the problem with this is that
i don't know if i can write here let me
see
the problem with this is that if i write
down my matrix let's say this one
then what what this information theory
term or information theoretics term
asks for is how different are the
distributions for the zero zero entry
and the zero one entry
well that can be zero why because i can
put them both into the same ring one
factor namely this one
right similar for the other one i this
one would be also zero if i try to
estimate them separately because i can
put these two in the same
rank one factor so there's no way if i
try to estimate them like this
to get an interesting lower bound what i
can do however is i can do this in a
slightly smarter
yeah i can do this in a slightly smarter
way
so let's write out what we have so we
had this term we we write out what we
want to estimate so we put in these
heading distance terms
but now we don't try to estimate them
separately but we estimate them
simultaneously
because the trick is why each one of
them can be zero independently of each
other
not both of them can be zero at the same
time and that is where our lower bond
will come from
and that's where the hellinger distance
comes in now
with its nice properties so the first
thing that i do is i apply the koshi
schwarz inequality
which allows me to get the square
outside and the 2 becomes a 4.
and now well this is actually a distance
so it's a metric so i can use triangle
inequality and i have the two zeros here
so that's effectively lower bounded by
uh the helium distance squared of
pi 0 1 0 and pi 0 1 and now divided by
4.
and this one here is very easy to
estimate because for this one we just
plug in the cut and paste property that
we had from beforehand
and that states that this term here is
just a lower bond by 1 minus
this ratio here that's the main diagonal
that's the off diagonal and the root of
that
so what's this ratio well we have 1
minus epsilon the main diagonal as a
product
we have 1 in the denominator so it's 1
minus root 1 minus epsilon
and then in terms i just do taylor
expansion i can lower bound by epsilon
half
you plug in everything and you get your
exponential lower bound on the extension
complexity of the correlation polytope
it also follows just from this very
simple type of argument
yeah so uh you can you can go
significantly further with these
techniques i'm not going
through this i just want to mention this
so there's so first thing that you get
from this when you write it out
correctly is you get that no lp
can approximate the correlation polytope
with a small linear program with an
effect of n to the 1 minus epsilon
you have seen that similar result
already or the same result already in
talk by
ankle moisture i think what you can
however also do is you can say a lot
about
say average type of complexity um for
these problems so if your example you
say okay
it seems like it's hard to solve this
problem exactly let me throw out 10
of the instances that i believe to be
very hard
is it still hard and it turns out that
with this information theoretic approach
you can
model all these types of adversarial uh
changes to the matrix and you still get
effectively exponential low bonds and
that various models you can
randomly remove matrices you can
adversarially remove matrices
in all cases you get very strong lower
bonds and yeah so
yeah so as mentioned earlier you can
push this even a bit further
so very recently thomas wrote through
proof with a very nice result that every
lp capturing the matching polytope has
to be of exponential size
that's interesting for a lot of reasons
first of all it separates
polytime computations from the size of
linear programs which
i believe is probably the very strong
insight that comes from this but what
you can also do is you can push this a
bit further with information theory and
you can talk about approximations of the
matching problem
so the matching problem can be pretty
well approximated within any constant
factor
just by chopping off the the odd sets
that you take
in your ip relaxation however if you
want to have an f peter style of
approximation
that behaves very nicely in in the
dimension
and the approximation factor uh then you
still need an exponential number of
inequalities to capture this and uh in
fact you get
you cannot approximate matching within
one plus epsilon over n
with an lp that is less than of
exponential size so although the problem
is probably normally time solvable you
cannot even approximate it well in some
sense
with linear programs
in fact it turns out at the core is an
argument that is very
in the information theoretic group it's
very similar to this it's just not that
you set this jointness on two you have
a two by k matrix but it's really a very
similar argument
yeah so that's uh that's all that i want
to say thank you very much
can you use these information theoretic
techniques to give um
lp lower bounds for problems like max
csps
uh yes you can and what sort
so you can so so you can but one thing
is i i don't know how much
so there's this paper but generally
regulator and story so this you can
replicate with an information theoretic
approach
um so you get the same type of lower
bounds um
it might be even possible with refining
the argument that you get strong allow
bonds in terms of the size and the
problems
so right now it's n to the log n by log
log n which is quasi polynomial but it
could be that you get even something
that is
stronger start with sure no actually we
don't
so you can you don't need cherry items
anymore yeah
so you start right on the instances that
you get from
cherry karma carriage of makarichev and
you write work on these instances
okay